today we're going to discuss the six
pauses
the B12 deficiency that you've never
heard before and this is really
important because if someone's deficient
B12 they can develop permanent damage
into the nervous system into the brain
they can have anemia they can have a
raised level of homocysteine which is
really bad for the heart and they can
actually be depressed and have all these
medications and treatments for Years yet
nothing even touches it because no one
addressed the B12 connection various
problems can happen with your eyes on
many different levels because you have
the retina which is all nerve tissue and
b12 is needed for anything neurological
a person can develop anemia because of
the importance of B12 in your red blood
cell and even problems within the DNA
the B12 is very very important and a
huge percentage of the population in the
world is deficient in B12 and many times
they have a subclinical B12 deficiency
and they don't even know it it's
important to know all the causes that go
beyond just lacking B12 in the diet
because you don't consume animal
products all right so let's just jump
right in the first one is an H pylori
infection okay I've read reports and I
had a hard time believing this but 50 of
the population has an H pylori infection
I don't know if I would agree with that
but I will say that it's a very very
high percentage but roughly 80 percent
of the population
as H pylori in their body whether it's
coming out of remission or not is really
depending on the environment of your
body but H pylori normally in our bodies
doesn't create a problem okay it lives
with our body it cooperates it's a good
relationship but when things change
environmentally it can become very very
nasty and it's the underlying cause
behind ulcers and gastritis and atrophy
of the stomach it can produce gerd
symptoms and so on and so on
unfortunately the treatments for it
involved multiple antibiotics and acids
like ppis and unfortunately there's a
lot of non-compliance when people do
this simply because they can't tolerate
this this treatment and then you start
developing resistance against these
antibiotics and now you're struck
between a rock and a hard place because
what are they going to do and so their
whole goal is to eradicate this H pylori
and just kill off this germ not take
taking consideration the rest of the
body
now if we really want to get rid of H
pylori we really want to put it back in
remission where it belongs
and that has everything to do with the
environment that this microbe lives in
and there's a couple things you need to
know about H pylori it is a neutral fill
now what is that that is
a microbe that prefers
a pH that is more neutral okay like
between 5.5 to 7.5 7 being neutral here
this microbe is existing in an
environment that is extremely acidic I
mean the normal pH of the stomach should
be between one and three right and so if
you go all the way up to neutral
wow you're going to have so many
problems in your stomach because you now
you can't defend against pathogens that
come through the digestive tract uh
you're not going to be able to digest
protein you're gonna have a lot of
issues with absorption of minerals but
this microbe prefers that pH as we age
the pH of your stomach becomes less and
less acidic and more and more neutral
this is where we have a problem however
this H pylori microbe also has enzymes
that increase ammonia which is extremely
alkaline and it's a survival mechanism
so if this microbe gains traction it
itself is going to create an alkaline
stomach and give you a lot of problems
with digestion and what is that going to
do that is going to greatly inhibit
B12 why because you need that acid
to break down the food to extract B12
B12 is in animal products right if you
can't digest the protein to extract the
B12 you're going to be deficient and not
only that H pylori will also deplete
your iron reserves your vitamin A your
vitamin C and your folic acid so what
would be a better approach or a better
strategy for this H pylori well number
one start acidifying your stomach if you
can but many people can't because they
have an ulcer or they have gastritis so
if you add more acid to the stomach
you're going to make it worse
so what can you do well guess what
broccoli Sprouts or even better yet
broccoli micro greens have sulfurophane
which is a compound of phytonutrient
that can kill H pylori okay there's many
other phytonutrients that can kill it
but sulforaphane is a great solution
another thing to take would be garlic
that garlic can kill off H pylori or at
least put it back in remission
probiotics have been found to inhibit H
pylori so here we have doctors
recommending antibiotics but why not
just use probiotics to really get that
thing back in check and just as a side
note if you're on antibiotics right now
you better be taking probiotics at the
exact same time because that way it will
protect you against some of the side
effects now a couple other things that
can help H pylori Clover and Manuka
Honey either or has been known to reduce
the infection of H pylori so number one
H pylori number two metformin one of the
side effects of metformin is a
deficiency of B12 as well as B1 okay so
if you're on Metformin you better be
taking B12 and B1 if someone's a
diabetic a lot of times they'll develop
what's called peripheral neuropathy on
the bottom of their feet they'll have
like numbness tingling things like that
and the remedy is taking some of these B
vitamins like B1 in the form of
benphotamine to help reverse it but if
you don't know that and you're taking
metformin that's creating a worsening of
this B1 slash B12 deficiency
this could be the reason why your
peripheral neuropathy and other
neuropathy problems are not going away
the medication is supposed to help you
is actually worsening the situation
number three is Snips now what is Snips
genetic variations is that give you a
propensity or a susceptibility of having
certain problems if your environment
isn't just right well there are three
genes that I know of that I'm not going
to get into that detail of that but you
should just know there are genes that
are involved with the conversion or
activation of B12 as well as the
absorption of B12 and it's not uncommon
to have a variation of a gene that
doesn't allow you to absorb the 12. and
this is simply because the genetics that
you were born with don't allow for the
maximum absorption of B12 and so when
I've been recently looking at DNA
testing with certain people that's kind
of showing up quite often
problem with B12 and they had no idea
and so the solution for that is to take
a natural form of B12 don't overtake the
synthetic version the natural one is
called methylcobolamine and the
synthetic version is called
cyanobolamine another solution is to
start consuming foods high in B12 the
natural version which would be red meat
and beef liver all right the fourth
reason why people are deficient in B12
is that they are taking synthetic
folic acid okay so folic acid is in our
Foods as a fortification as an
enhancement as an enrichment they use
folic acid in pretty much all the
cereals that you hopefully are not
eating they also put it in the breads
the pasta the crackers the biscuits
grain products right anything that's
refined it's in nutritional yeast it's
in a lot of the supplements it's in a
lot of the energy bars that people have
and unfortunately it can build up in the
body to a point where it's toxic
especially if someone has a genetic
problem with folic acid which is very
common and what happens with this
consumption of this folic acid okay or
this accumulation of folic acid is you
start to hide a deficiency of B12 and
that can create big problems with B12
methylfolate is a good full acid that
doesn't have to convert okay so it
doesn't need that enzyme that many
people have a problem with so that's
something you can do the next cause of a
B12 deficiency is laughing gas right you
go to the dentist and they give you a
laughing gas which I've had in the past
and that can create a B12 deficiency and
the last reason is ppis these are
antacids in fact it's one of the
treatments for h pylori which can then
create a B12 deficiency indirectly so
antacids increase your risk of this H
pylori and so I just wanted to create
this video to increase your awareness on
the six additional reasons why someone
could be B12 deficient and now you know
about them you can do something about
them now since B12 is related to folic
acid if you haven't seen this video
you should check it out I put it up
right here